[Musica]
che cosa hanno di diverso queste due
paia di jeans
oltre a qualche dettaglio rifinitura non
sembrano particolarmente diversi eppure
questo paio di jeans ha richiesto oltre
10 mila litri d'acqua per essere
prodotto mentre questo 200 questo è
stato prodotto in una fabbrica in cui
lavoratori sono spesso minorenni e privi
di tutele mentre questo in una fabbrica
certificata in cui il salario è equo e
garantito
purtroppo la maggior parte dei nostri
vestiti oggi è fatta come questo primo
paio di jeans però oggi vi racconterò
come ognuno di noi può contribuire a un
sistema moda più virtuoso sostenibile ed
etico
personalmente mi sono avvicinata a
questo mondo in maniera piuttosto
casuale
era il 2017 e stavo facendo il quarto
anno di liceo all'estero in canada e
come forse alcuni di voi sapranno in
canada si tende a studiare leggermente
meno rispetto al liceo italiano e quindi
avevo molto più tempo libero da dedicare
ai miei interessi e ho guardato
tantissimi documentari su argomenti
veramente diversi l'uno dall'altro
ho guardato documentario sulla crisi
climatica ma anche sulla crisi
finanziaria del 2008 e tra questi uno mi
ha colpito più degli altri
questo ed è sul cost di andrew morgan è
un documentario che parla dell'impatto
ambientale ed etico dell'industria della
moda
personalmente mi ha colpito molto più
degli altri perché non immaginavo
assolutamente che dietro ai nostri
vestiti ci fosse così tanta sofferenza
alla base del sistema moda e dei suoi
errori c'è
un modo di produrre vestiti un business
model chiamato fast fashion
non so quanti di voi in sala sono a
conoscenza di questo termine però è un
po simile al fast food quindi è basato
sulla velocità e sull'eccesso il fast
fashion a due principali problemi è un
problema di quantità e un problema di
qualità un problema di quantità perché
si producono tanti troppi vestiti
infatti mentre una volta si aveva la
collezione primavera estate e la
collezione autunno inverno
adesso si arrivano a produrre 52
collezioni l'anno a volte anche di più e
ovviamente sono molto difficili da
smaltire questi vestiti che finiscono in
discarica e sono difficili da riciclare
e poi sia un problema di qualità perché
questi vestiti sono creati per non
durare infatti sono vestiti creati con
budget molto molto bassi che sono
studiati per rompersi in lavatrice dopo
pochi lavaggi e non permettono neanche
di retribuire in maniera equa i propri
lavoratori malfa station è anche un
problema per noi consumatori infatti noi
non ci guadagniamo ad acquistare moda
così noi compriamo ma le compriamo
sempre di più e compriamo sempre peggio
e quindi spendiamo soldi che potrebbero
essere investiti in capi migliori in
vestiti che ci dureranno veramente poco
il fast fashion è problematico in tutte
le fasi della filiera forse voi lo
sapevate che i pesticidi non sono
utilizzati solo nella produzione di cibo
io fino a qualche anno fa non lo sapevo
però i pesticidi vengono utilizzati
molto nella produzione di una delle
fibre che noi tutti indossiamo ovvero il
cotone in india circa 5,8 milioni di
persone lavorano nel settore della
coltivazione del cotone e molte di
queste si ammalano gravemente e muoiono
anche a causa di dei pesticidi
utilizzati che causano gravi malattie
respiratorie e tumori
se anche un problema di microplastiche
qua vedete un maglione di acrilico un
costume di nylon e delle scarpe da
ginnastica e cosa hanno in comune questi
vestiti il fatto di essere composti da
plastica da materiale sintetico il
problema del materiale sintetico è che
quando noi lo laviamo in lavatrice le
nostre lavatrici non sono in grado di
filtrare questi piccolissimi pezzettini
di fibra che vengono rilasciati e quindi
finiscono in mare vengono consumati dai
pesci e poi rientrano nella nostra
catena alimentare
sia anche un problema di inquinamento
idrico infatti molte delle tinture
utilizzate per produrre i nostri vestiti
non sono sostenibili e rendono anche
completamente sterili alcuni terreni che
sono di solito utilizzati dalle
popolazioni locali per coltivare quindi
rendendoli completamente incoltivabili e
infine un inquinamento più classico di
cui siamo tutti a conoscenza quello da
co2 anche qui l'industria della moda non
se la cava molto meglio infatti
responsabile circa dell'otto per cento
di emissioni di co2
lei è sì ma cima è una ragazza bengalese
che da quando è molto giovane lavora per
fabbriche di fast fashion e ovviamente
lavora in condizioni pessime lavora in
condizioni veramente pericolose per
tante ore al giorno tra agenti chimici
dannosi e per questa ragione ha deciso
di fondare un sindacato con le sue
colleghe e di presentare le richieste ai
manager della fabbrica cima e le sue
colleghe sono state chiuse all'interno
della fabbrica e sono state picchiate
con sedie forbici e bastoni
purtroppo la maggior parte dei nostri
nostri vestiti è prodotta in questo modo
e io quando ho scoperto tutto ciò sono
rimasta veramente
sconvolta qui vedete il crollo del rana
plata era una plaza era una fabbrica in
cui si producevano vestiti di fast
fashion e non solo
e nonostante le segnalazioni da parte
degli operai
per quanto riguardava crepet e danni
strutturali non si era fatto nulla per
ripararle e quindi gli operai sono morti
sepolti sotto le macerie appunto di
questa fabbrica e sono morte
1129 persone questo il 24 aprile del
ora
immaginate me a 17 anni davanti al
computer che scopre tutte queste cose
nel giro di circa un'ora e mezza
probabilmente indossando vestiti
incriminati per mesi non volevo comprare
nulla ero veramente sconvolta l'idea che
dietro qualcosa di così futile come i
nostri vestiti ci potesse essere così
tanta sofferenza e io non volevo cedere
a queste dinamiche non volevo supportare
aziende che non si allineavano per
niente con i miei valori e quindi ho
iniziato a cercare alternative su
internet ho cercato magliette ecologiche
jeans etici non trovato quasi nulla nel
e però c'era qualche articolo in inglese
tuttavia ero abbastanza sicura di non
essere l'unica interessata questo
argomento anche perché il documentario
si poteva vedere anche in italiano e
quindi ho aperto un gruppo facebook per
confrontarmi lingua italiana con altri
consumatori interessati a questa
industria più virtuosa
nel giro di pochissimo tempo abbiamo
raggiunto molti input interessanti
questi sono solo alcuni dei post della
community facebook che ha consigliato di
tutto da negozi dell'usato a negozi
sostenibili a sarti che utilizzano
stoffe di recupero e mi sono resa conto
di quanto fossero preziosi tutti questi
suggerimenti
allora inizialmente li ho scritti in un
documento word che poi ho caricato sullo
stesso gruppo facebook e presto mi sono
resa conto che
non si trattava di un sistema
particolarmente user friendly perché
erano pagine e pagine di link e parole e
quindi dopo poco ho creato anche un sito
web
questo sito web è cambiato negli anni e
adesso è diviso in tre parti principali
la prima una parte dove raccogliamo
suggerimenti merito agli commerce di
moda sostenibile
abbiamo aziende che producono vestiario
di ogni genere dalla sarta che recupera
stoffe vintage all'azienda che usa
metalli da bombe disinnescate per creare
gioielli all'azienda che ricicla il
cashmere
poi abbiamo una parte di mappa perché
sapevamo che non tutti amano acquistare
online molti preferiscono acquistare dal
vivo provare le cose addosso anch'io
preferisco acquistare nei negozi e
quindi abbiamo creato anche una parte di
mappa dove sono presenti negozi
dell'usato di vintage di noleggio abiti
per occasioni speciali
equosolidali e sono sparsi su tutto il
territorio italiane sono oltre 1600 e
poi c'è una parte di blog
io sono pienamente convinta del fatto
che noi non possiamo essere consumatori
sostenibili se non siamo perfettamente
consapevoli di cosa stiamo acquistando e
per questa ragione abbiamo creato guide
su materiali più o meno sostenibili ma
anche buone notizie come le start up di
moda sostenibile italiane più virtuose
più recenti oppure anche idee regalo su
come acquistare appunto
sostenibilmente regali per natale o per
compleanni
ora voi penserete tutto un volto bello
grazie di averlo condiviso però io cosa
c'entro
centri centrate infatti noi tutti
abbiamo un potere molto molto forte e io
credo che comunque il percorso di
sostenibilità sia un percorso
estremamente personale però se non
sapete da dove iniziare
potrei darvi 5 spunti
il primo è cambiare prospettiva perché
noi non possiamo pensare di acquistare
moda sostenibile come acquistiamo fast
fashion dobbiamo acquistare meno cose ma
migliori che dureranno a lungo ripararle
e prendersi cura degli oggetti che
abbiamo
punto 2 conosci il costo per uso non
sempre la maglietta col cartellino 3
euro e più economica della maglietta col
cartellino 25 euro perché perché una
maglietta che questo 3 euro e che si
distrugge dopo due o tre lavaggio in
lavatrice a un costo per uso molto più
alto rispetto a una maglietta che magari
costa 20 25 euro ma che se durerà per
anni e anni
numero 3 seconda mano negli ultimi
decenni abbiamo abbiamo prodotto così
tanti vestiti da poter vivere di vestiti
di seconda mano praticamente per sempre
quindi vi consiglio di andare nella
bottega sotto casa ci sono tantissimi
mercatini dell'usato in italia e di
spulciare e trovare il capo più adatto a
voi
quarto punto conosci i materiali i
materiali non sono tutti uguali anche lo
stesso materiale può essere più o meno
sostenibile per esempio il cotone può
essere un cotone certificato
got che è una certificazione che
garantisce un ridotto consumo di acqua e
un uso dei pesticidi molto diverso
rispetto anche un cotone tradizionale ma
anche tra i materiali sintetici c'è
differenza per esempio un nylon
tradizionale è diverso da un nylon
riciclato in italia per esempio esiste
un'azienda che produce nylon da reti da
pesca e altri rifiuti di plastica
e poi ultimo consiglio ma forse il più
importante sparge la voce e dai
l'esempio noi non viviamo in una bolla
viviamo con altre persone viviamo in una
società e quindi tutte le nostre azioni
hanno un impatto molto forte non
soltanto perché l'azione di per sé è
buona ma perché questa azione viene
osservata in maniera molto attenta dagli
altri spesso quindi quando noi
acquistiamo usato
noi stiamo mandando un messaggio faccio
anche tutte le persone che ci circondano
un messaggio positivo di economia
circolare e negli anni ho capito che
dare l'esempio è molto più importante
rispetto a fare le ramanzine sulla
sostenibilità
io negli anni sono veramente contenta di
ciò che il sito il progetto è diventato
e
non me l'aspettavo per niente
al momento sono comunque una studentessa
universitaria a tempo pieno e non so in
che direzione si evolverà questo
progetto ciò che però so è che in questi
anni siamo riusciti a far riflettere
centinaia di migliaia di persone
sull'origine dei nostri vestiti e questo
è oltre ogni aspettativa della me
diciassettenne e mareggiata davanti al
computer grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]